we've been reporting a high-stakes
summit is underway in scotland that's
being called the last hope to stop
catastrophic climate change nearly 200
countries are represented there and
among their goals to secure a deal on
global net zero emissions by 2050 and to
limit the planet's warming mark phillips
is in glasgow where scientists say the
time to tackle this well it's slipping
away mark good morning
good morning tony well they call this
conference cop 26 because it's the 26th
time that world leaders have gathered to
try to limit global warming in fact this
conference was supposed to be held a
year ago but was delayed because of
covid the extra preparation time though
doesn't seem to have increased its
chances of success
what's being called the last chance
saloon to avoid the worst effects of
climate change is a futuristic
conference center where the future is
beginning to look as bleak as the
weather
the leaders of the world are gathering
here with some notable exceptions to try
to make good on the promise they made in
paris six years ago
there the cheering was about the
agreement to try to limit global warming
to 2.7 degrees
1.5 degrees celsius beyond which the
effects of climate change become
unmanageable
but paris was about ambition not
practicalities to meet the goals world
governments were supposed to make
increasingly larger cuts in their
greenhouse gas emissions in the future
but the future is now and the required
cuts haven't been made
the fires the storms the heat waves the
melting polar ice and rising sea levels
we've seen so far are but a taste of
what could come
what we did not know
is or could not have foreseen is that
science would be screaming from the
rooftops by now christiana figueres is
widely credited with banging heads
together to make the paris deal happen
that everything that science had
actually
looked at
was
underestimated
and in terms of the degree of heating
that was in terms of the degree of
heating the impacts the human misery
costs the infrastructure it's all
happening faster than you ever feared
all happening faster than we ever
thought
the scientific calculation is that
planet-warming greenhouse gas emissions
need to be halved by the end of this
decade
as it stands now they will continue to
rise
and the international political will
that made the paris deal possible isn't
there this time the chinese president xi
jinping isn't even coming anyone that
goes to cop 26 to expect that we're
going to guarantee a pathway to 1.5 is
simply not seeing the reality of things
we're just not going to get there
the whole point of these meetings is to
force the issue that the face-to-face
will actually hold politicians feet to
the fire that's tough to do and some of
the more notable ones she of china putin
of russia aren't here nate
i'll take this one uh mark it does speak
volumes when the top leaders of russia
and china are not on the scene there in
scotland but you are and we appreciate
that we'll stay with you all week mark
thank you very much